[Music]  in today's modern world you can watch  what you're doing or you can watch where  you're going but you can't do both and  now you don't have to  thanks to guiding hands at guiding hands  we understand how important it is to  stay connected when you're on the go  simply request a guiding hand and within  two seconds we'll be at your side ready  to guide you to your destination  let us navigate your world so you can  navigate the web your guiding hand will  prepare all the pesky distractions that  once forced you to look up we look out  for you so you can keep an eye on the  things that matter  enjoy the security that comes in knowing  you are finally truly connected you'll  never have to look up again  [Applause]  that's in front  [Applause]  guiding hand we got this  you  you